[Music]
in unintentional use news submitted by
about her chicken bottle chicken I like
about her chicken yeah by the chickens
good Indian people you know so Microsoft
employees are protesting a contract to
supply the military with headsets
intended for use on the battlefield
they're protesting it why supplying the
military with the headset Microsoft
employees cuz they're against war dating
and they didn't sign up to be a part of
all like a military that's fair what is
it just their headsets or but don't
companies just make things right and
then it's up to the sales people or the
executive board they stay sell it off
recently got a four hundred eighty
million dollar contract to supply the US
Army with augmented reality headsets
intended for use on the battlefield okay
yes so they're the employees are saying
like hold on the [ __ ] like we didn't
sign up to this [ __ ] like we didn't
agree to you're supposed to be four
dudes in the living room jacking off the
pornos supposed to be for like doctors
or like oh let me show you a video of
well I don't understand let me show you
a video the actual cosmetics
it's called hololens and this is where
it you're a hollow lives thank you oh my
[Music]
it sounds epic I want one that is pretty
dope Minority Report that's like some
Ironman [ __ ] dude
AR is pretty tight Wow way better than a
global glasses
[Music]
so now it's like gonna be precision
killing
[Music]
I want to live in a world like that
[Music]
this is wild
I'll be so funny if you don't have your
lens on and you're doing this magic [ __ ]
you want to do a [ __ ] like that are you
Apple I don't even know what that lens
does so it's augmented reality yeah that
like you could work with oh that's tight
so it's like they're in the battlefield
and if they need to [ __ ] look at the
blueprint of that house or whatever they
go like maybe maybe like that in there I
don't think it's in real-life combat I
think it's for training I know it says
met to be used on the battlefield oh
[ __ ] because it's assisting them in
being efficient to increase lethality
so it says enhancing the ability to
detect decide and engage before the
enemy like I thought so yes it makes
sense so yeah those they it would be
holographic images into the wearer's
field of vision why wouldn't you want
your country soldiers to have an edge so
they said we are a global coalition of
Microsoft Workers and we refuse to
create technology for warfare we are
alarmed that Microsoft is working to
provide weapons technology to the US
military helping one country's
government increased lethality using
tools we built we did not sign up to
develop weapons and we demand a say in
our and how our work is used I guess not
two issues with it the first word
lethality might be the wrong word to use
because the more effective you are the
more life-saving it is for your tongue
so they can consider it it's it brings
our soldiers home better and the second
thing like if you're like a GM worker
and you work on Chevy trucks right
you're just working you're just working
for a car company and if it just so
happens that the government is now gonna
buy all the Tahoe's for all the CIA
agents isn't that just their thing right
like what does the Tahoe mechanics have
to do with how when you work for a
company though you should it should be
disclosed to what you're working for
unless you sign something and in your
example they're not these guys are the
engineers right we're all the like
inventing they are
it's almost like their IP exactly that's
why it's different well even if the
other way around too if you were
building a part that was specifically
geared to kill somebody that would
probably [ __ ] with your borscht exactly
so what a quote from one of the software
developers who worked on the hololens
for two years but then he ended up
leading he said although I believe in
security and military action for a
morally justifiable cause I take issue
with the language of lethality which you
just said he said there are appropriate
applications for mixed reality in a
military setting but I would not want to
be designing an experience where my goal
was to official to more efficiently kill
people so they have like a moral yeah I
could understand them I understand that
to the area I get it but it's just like
really simple if you're not gonna do it
they're not gonna turn down a 460
million dollar government contract you
know the result yeah exactly
it's like you have moral issues with it
that's fine but I guess as an employee
and someone at that position you would
hope that this company that you're
giving your life to basically would have
your back and would be like hey you know
what and yeah this is this is like a new
utopian thing right but it'd be like
it'd be tight to be like hey you know
what guys we're about to get this
contract its most likely gonna come
through this is your now we're giving
you the heads up do you want to stay
here or you might want to be relocated
to another position within the company
whereas to now they're like [ __ ] like
well I'm just gonna bounce cuz they
don't give a [ __ ] about me because I
think it was stated to right originally
the reason why they hopped onto this was
because they wanted to use it for the
medical purses and that's what it was
intended for it on them yeah another
Microsoft employee said quote a lot of
people feel uncomfortable about being
involved in war-related business or
producing weapons that hurt other people
to me it's a basic violation of
Microsoft's mission statement to empower
every person and organization on the
planet to do more I can see that it's
like those people like the scientists
are recruited to work on like plutonium
or something oh cool it's an alternative
energy and then you find out it's for a
nuclear bomb but what the [ __ ] that's
not what I'm here to research and like
engineer for I could totally see if
these they flip the script on yeah if
it's like a bait and switch I think that
makes it even worse but if there was
like almost kind of like
open-ended where it's like yes this is
the technology that we're gonna use it
for but there's other things that can
come in too
picture as his technology like gets
fleshed out I just can't wait for some
dope-ass like realistic VR dude just
take me away to a [ __ ] eyelid big
ready player one huh yeah one of those
days oh where am i naive [ __ ]
what's going on dude just nice and then
somebody just blows with in my face yes
just spitting on me huh mary'll can you
brush your teeth before you blonde me
thank you in coconut I'm in the bras can
you push me in the face now please
hahahahaha I bought like a VR kind of
thing for my niece's and you can go to
like big tourist destinations like
Athens or whatever and when you're when
you're in it like you you hook it up to
your phone actually you download the app
and then you you put like a bomb at yeah
we got it with the Google box yeah and
you go like this and you can look around
and you could either push forward or
backward yeah and then you still gotta
like click but it's pretty cool how like
you could go all around and you look up
and down and [ __ ] every time I see it in
the drawer I'm like I want to throw this
away about my guys it's all like he
still uses it yeah sometimes yeah it
does spark joy so I had to keep it dude
there are so many things that don't
spark joy in my life
I [ __ ] donated all that [ __ ] I'm
trying to get rid of my goddamn shoes
now they don't spark joy no but I
realized too that we also need some
shoes for secret society so that's gonna
keep them for like the shoots and stuff
right yeah for the shoes so I'm just
gonna give to huszai I was about to sell
them and they put them on offer up and
first of all offer up people are the
most what's offer it's like a Craig's
List but yeah we see how no only in
front of you there huh when you [ __ ]
up you're so cute hold it up
all of us everyone she was just waiting
you like this quietly for eight hours I
said mental institutions yeah so it's
like the dumbest thing so I put up these
shoes right it was like these uh these
nmds and there was like one of the first
all of models and get that [ __ ] up there
for like on goat for like two hundred
bucks right so I was putting it up for
just ninety dollars just to get rid of
it fast this guy was like dude you can
get this in store right now for 60 bucks
it's an older model you should make it
for cheaper i was like i wrote LOL
that's not how shoes work like this cuz
is older it actually appreciates invalid
you dumbass and as I learned that haggle
better buy right and he comes back and
I'm such a petty [ __ ] he goes he
goes fine I'll buy for ninety I was like
sorry man I'm - L - I sold for 120 and I
didn't do it that's why I like using
that [ __ ] I love trolling people like on
Craigslist like I'm not intentionally
trying to troll but I'm selling
something and then these people come at
me like that I just roll the [ __ ] out of
them hate that [ __ ] and then that's why
I go to Walmart cuz I like seeing weird
people it goes real [ __ ] one time one
time it was like maybe 12:00 or 1:00 in
the morning
right I went to a 24-hour Walmart I see
this a janitor like mopping the floor
he's like maybe about two hours away but
then there's like open spaces between
the aisle so I see him I don't really
think much of it and then he's like you
know walking down the aisle and then he
comes out of the aisle and I see his
full body there's four had a [ __ ] mop
handle with no bottom on the mop and he
was wearing a janitor outfit but he
wasn't actually a Walmart no one else
saw him dude janitor that worked in that
hospital that before he could clean up
his mess
attack ad I'm fine I know maybe right
and his name was Michael Mick moppy and
at that same Walmart I saw like a three
year old and like a four year old just
running around by themselves like where
are your [ __ ] parents at like is one
I've I always see kids running around at
the 24-hour you think goes all the time
and you just don't realize you've got
the experience that you wanted mmm but I
didn't know it oh yeah where are your
parents children they died from the
plague we're trying to sell a $300 TV
stand right now it actually went up in
value when we bought it for like 270 or
some [ __ ] it's like 300 now on Amazon
right stand up and value yeah it really
[ __ ] value that's the most I mean you
assemble it yourself but I guess it's in
high demand so it's it's 300 bucks right
now right and then we got an offer for
$75 offer up so ridiculous I would have
taken it for half 150 bucks cool what I
go hit him up right now y'all $75 lost
them and they say like cash like that's
gonna make a difference I'll give you 75
- yeah right now I don't like that [ __ ]
do you mean you're not gonna charge it
yeah somebody else - I have like these
ajks
it's like these dragged toward and bred
ones I try to sell it to and I was only
for 50 bucks I've ordered a few times
but as I [ __ ] I warrant so let's sell
it right
this guy's like I could get it for $30
on eBay is what he wrote me and I just
will [ __ ] go on eBay then jackass and
I wrote that [ __ ] back and I left it at
that
why the [ __ ] would you send me that
people do not know how to handle you're
so [ __ ] dumb
[Music]